pourquoi est-ce qu'on a envoyé un bateau
de sauvetage en jeu
en pot
au péril de sa propre sécurité il s'est
courageusement jeter au coeur de la
tempête sauver ginza
[Applaudissements]
premier jeu
tu es bien eliacin oui c'est moi c'est
nous rapportera au sommaire ce rasta
bateau facile pendant la monnaie avant
tout n'arrêtez pas avec toi tu es un
véritable héros aulas aimerait que tu
devenir le nouveau bateau de sauvetage
du grand port mourra si tu réussis au
grand port tu peux réussir n'importe
sauvetage
c'est quoi une sorte de stagiaires sont
vraiment super chouette
ça va tu fais pas par nous trouvons
croix bonhomme et si rooney les
spécialistes des gros sous
qu'est ce qui est du critérium creuser
ça ne me dit rien qui vaille
[Musique]
et big boss tu serais pas du genre un
peu coincé qui moi n'ont carrément pas
non s'agace